oh okay Ivan hold on keep going let it
rock okay hey hey I don't know what he's
listening it could be whatever it needs
to be today baby that looks like the
dance of a winner talk to me baby the
footwork yeah we are the West goes over
right oh is this DJ gonna play like that
and we gonna put him on the mixtape you
know we got boom in the crowd little
mixtapes as you know musical crowd here
today he might be too powerful this way
honestly oh he's like wait you knowing
you you holding up the show my man I
think Signia right now I was actually
playing mooch he's trying to ice our man
by stalling him out he's he's trying to
let that see it Celine Dion the mind
games oh they make sure y'all get that
clipped and I need that floating around
Twitter right now especially who that
wins oh yes please might get a little
bit fancier he might move that fine
dxracer chair out of the way only to
figure out the next game you'll be
playing it's like got a long way to go
and he's trying to bop his way
throughout the bracket but will it be
enough sitting yeah in all likelihood
coming through with a Yoshi slow things
down we're punishing and I really want
to know I don't care who wins anymore
what is he listening to I need answers
we gonna line down after we don't really
need that postgame interview we gonna
find out let's get up in the boat I mean
you talked about it earlier though we
like signior be on the west coast yes
the homies are here in full force to
cheer for their boy to cheer for some
proper neutral oh it's a chance easily
access a neutral is only accessible for
singing Wow who dat finally locking in
its gonna
stand back up nevermind that handshake
in party all the time we'll take that
that's that's the law
that's what the voice alright well one
thing he certain pleasing as well
definitely believes in his ability you
should to it that you're ready to fire
this one off Signia III definitely
believe in some as law and you already
know KP that's my band's they report
throughout all of this is that Signia
has not moved a muscle
my man is like okay stop with the
gimmicks stop with all the theatrics
let's sit down into what we came to do
losers Tom sixteen action pay attention
who'd adverts insignia we got four
teleporter rolls and start things up
early the most teleports I've seen since
uh post patch all right fire it up damn
careful
yeah tricking them with the chaos right
there to get them into the muscle buster
situation you wanted to get high but
okay no sweet right back at you while
she's live one gets clocked no punished
though I guess he wasn't insane a little
too funky there grape locks likely to
win here and shield gonna get that
launch instead it has to go into that
boom time and time again is who day I
was gonna see just how far can carry him
and a single tournament looking for the
dunk and just when the ball sorry you
want to talk deuteronomy amy body
how do you play neutral versus rings
like that man you want to stand it the
most effective range for your most
effective moves and in that situation
there was none better who dad giving us
a lesson is facing as he takes round one
now it's the long way to go possible
which is crazy because theyíre i ran him
down as he tries to roll out which is
further towards the corner we gotta get
something michael buster oh what a doc
dog and I've run a duck right back who
that alright keep it safe not trying to
take too many risks again all of these
small hits pile up what again when
you're facing an entire life bar against
a single sequence you might have to take
a risk or two I mean
we're gonna come to as well I feel like
him taking a risk is probably gonna end
up being that entire life part yeah but
you also have to look at the amount of
wins right it's just one round a piece
you don't wanna start throwing out all
your greatest damn pits and your biggest
risk so that's a I can't get the
download or glitch bad you want to side
stuff just out of the range of that age
and hit them with the muscle cluster get
that extra damage right now in guts
range you got shorts damn Pondexter okay
switch backs yeah beautiful whip on his
desk on stick Mia's gonna spend some
poor put a little busted on it right
quick and he's gonna mix up fishing I
found him he was trying to either see
your soul charge I missed exactly which
one it was caught him out of it though
and that's gonna be the route that
counter hits stun and signior with the
immediate wherewithal to pick things up
and close things out to the one unfazed
continue on a lot of those were the gods
of caliber right there over both say
you're playing too good I need to break
you back down to earth and make that
whip all right drop the combo no
surprise there is a reasonable that get
this follow-up absolutely all right take
advantage a break attack watch your legs
that's what I'm saying you up for baby
we in here you're asking the wrong
questions y'all saw that right take
everybody's so upset I love that [ __ ]
I'm upset keeping safe oh you gotta put
in chess you gotta let him feel you know
up there and again you audio a banach
actually flinched in the booth because
he thought that I was gonna clean it as
well I saw all right back in the sole
charge again as well enhance what a
message to right here you should be a
pretty the break attack bus frame trying
to push for it oh yeah didn't press
those buttons there no clean it but
finally the clean hit they're back to
back and who's gonna go up one game to
take in the sights and leave a plating
his way in I want to take advantage snow
got just enough our fire be applause
yeah use that meter brooms in the crowd
nope
like bottom block on the low right there
and then the punish no
- on the law and you went too big on the
risk there at the end he didn't
necessarily need to pixels on his magic
pixels didn't even like fill up on the
life point it was like two or three of
them it just looked like a glitch in the
matrix but it's dead it's called rising
in the camera happy actually saying the
whole episode ya know let it rock I got
a for real though I got to give it a
credit to who dad though I keeping the
composure in that last scramble it was
it looked real weird once uh once he did
super fly to get up there and get past
but uh it was like an out scramble
situation but he kept his composure if
he was able to block the he'll sweep and
then he finished them off with a clean
punch yeah not to be completely
overshadowed that was three rounds into
last hit last iteration and Signia laws
because he reversed it on the sweep that
got blocked any different opportunity a
different choice and we talked about
having to take risk sometimes you know
we in Vegas baby you gotta roll that die
a couple of minutes there with the
breakdance having nothing but downer
here but didn't quite necessarily
recognize it it's time to get anything
bigger and that's situation one more
hint and then this is a 50/50 right here
yeah so he got the lethal hit so that
that is just a straight-up 50/50 you got
a deal with you they're back crab and
you duck or you get the hit by the
lethal
okay good fat yeah I believe that's a BA
slide all right so you saying I bet it
all on black
well I got something for you how about
these spinning blades that look just as
impressive one a into the throw sit down
be humble
okay it's got to do with the mix-up
after it goes for the low and then the
hell's he could block another punish I
think he's punished just about every
single one he bought yeah definitely
looking for it in that situation put
rolls up into a launch gonna get some
healthy damage right into an Okie
situation plus Sigma just happen up one
foot at a time making him watch himself
you don't send dutchman feet off before
you come inside this house okay yeah I
mean he's been trying to step outside
just of insignias range but the problem
is insignia started to age
in closer for it to make him a little
bit uncomfortable in those ranges in
incorrectly guess right and say that got
him to round on that one having known of
his single his you know another right
now who dad is trying to get some office
going and like sick be is like yo she's
just like my mama said I can't let
nobody in so you got to play outside of
the porch that just look it as you try
to get something going sing me a denial
of everything right up until this old
truck Oh 100 just barely missing the 6
PP right there he does take the throne
he's able to get away but yeah I mean
he's in mix-up City right now he has no
health and yeah I mean you just gotta
guess at that point right so yeah taking
that to the bank one to one right now
and I just want to play the game you bro
hey we can't come in I'm gonna clean my
room
you're the say from the outside and
watch have some friends over signals
like okay last time I let him in he beat
me at the game right so I'm purposely
not do my chores I must practice and
then when I cook up and let him in again
is gonna be curtains and closed doors
going into Game three a bit of the step
you know he's gone from Michael Jackson
to great you know I'm saying in terms of
dance moves he's just dancing all the
time happier all over the place and so
I'll do something occasionally and then
when I do what it looks bad on the
hotline thing exactly was a beam yeah
you know it especially because it wasn't
nearly as close that was that was all
sitting in that last game
open up and up with Axl Oh helium self
enact Sam's you know I mean most people
were so you said as well putting them in
start at the very brown sorry just
wasn't looking for it I got hey Siri
checking up with single button this type
of with punish on the sidestep insignia
went into the bag he said oh I didn't
eat enough couch feeds for this one let
me get about two more and that was all
it takes
nice stuff right there those thing you
know about capitalizing and being able
to get the ring out right there first
round regardless of the duck
I've got enough help I have confidence
even though is extremely close they gave
one am i watching the same singing or
did this man just straight-up evolved
mid-set I mean you could evolve what if
you get this leaflet okay nice he did
not text well you did not have to deal
with the 50/50 but he's gonna get the
deal with this 50/50 right here gets the
back though look at the damage the hello
you can't take these won't get the
punish on that he's gonna have to deal
with his own mixup on this okay blocks
it and there it is the spear low who dad
coming right back with the weight bashes
even
oh yeah he's definitely got those words
yeah this movement we've seen all day
but no life fleet is safe is so tells
especially when you have our girls in
there playing dangerously along these
corners what a lethal aid is gonna say
wait a mate of Signia let me slow you
down maybe he just like use the powerup
that gave up that boost in the second
round and it's like worn off for the
power Reese is gonna come into play here
let's see how he approaches a game use 1
9 K to get a buzzer but unfortunately he
wasn't able to catch the tech but he
block that muscle bustle right so he's
gonna catch the kid please dance here we
go mix up okay he just presses button
yeah nice trade there in that situation
to get him down out the air at the very
least doesn't want to deal with the both
men working towards the middle of stage
again here's a GI
taking of looking for follow-up in a
stand he just blocks 60 but
go for the follow-up and as signior does
though he's gonna get a grip of damage
but here's a mix up and it's the mid
signior right now set point
I sent my silly talk to me buddy gonna
figure this out one table one now I mean
he's got food I've got two bars right
now we all know absolution is coming at
some point oh wow she's in the back
separate tragedy okay there's a freebie
you see he's trying to take advantage
and baby save as possible walking into a
situation one at Pisco for yellow
flashing guard gauged and enough
offensive pressure coming in from signal
is to it let's have a fire what Bob one
a lot of the damage he was getting
earlier was from just scrape Ivy's right
and sometimes and so you need so I guess
he started to go back to write that and
he's just yeah straight I'm gonna
disrespect you all day so yeah he waved
dancing the muscle Buster there but he
saves himself does signior with the
50/50 on it oh hold up wait a minute I
mean that's the signature that's easy
that's the signature he does that that
it be like that I know you're scared KP
but it's like he can't reach you up here
he's a tall man but he can't reach you
up here to check the glasses he does
have reach though cuz I can't have this
man just jumping it's okay you can't
reach I just got to make sure man
because I felt that fire all the way up
here congratulations the Signia still
very much alive in this but that's Ernie
it's still beginning you have to win
this event that still has reached its
end
o-tama all these guys it's crazy
speaking of Sandman something we saw
early on and tomahawk as well I think he
actually set the stream off was one of
the first matches on street